that my father
says um what you think about Federal
I'm like I'm happy in Kansas City
so he introduces me this guy with the
Secret Service
and I talked to this guy and uh he says
you know
I've traveled all over the world with
the Secret Service
and I remember thinking
somebody paid you and paid for your
flights and paid for your hotel to go
all over the world like I'm from Iowa
like I you know I'd seen Canada from a
distance that was the extent of my
international travel
so I'm like that sounds cool and so I
didn't know one Federal agency from
another
no idea
Secret Service I will go down there
we're not hiring not hiring
so I see an article in the newspaper uh
FBI's first billion dollar budget
I knew enough about budgets and I
thought it's got to be salaries they're
going to be hiring
I went down I put in it was the first of
a three-year hiring push
and uh and I got in
and just like that so how long is it
between when you get accepted and when
you're going to the FBI Academy
yeah well
October 31st
I'd had three years on the police
department
and I would have gone to the SWAT team
the bureau hired me on October 15th
and I remember you know I'm a dumb 20
something year old
I put in
for the bureau
and I remember literally telling people
you know whoever whoever offers me a
position first
the SWAT team comes I'm going with a
SWAT team the bureau comes I'm going
with the bureau
and then they kept uh the police
department had had a the chief at the
time hated the FBI with a passion hated
the FBI
so they had a rule
that if you left the police department
the only job you couldn't come back from
was it you became an FBI agent a Hugo
took a job as a dog catcher they'd take
it back you go take a job you know think
of something a hairdresser you know I
don't know what
but the only job and in my exit
interview they they literally told me
they said you understand you can never
come back if you joined a bureau like
well it's not my intention to come back
but so consequently they had to I had to
keep my application a secret until it
was in a final stages they couldn't go
interview any of my commanders until
just they were sure that they were going
to hire me at the last minute
and you know that led I was still a
mouthy 20 something so that led to a
couple of problems as I was leaving the
police department what's the beef
where's the beef did this guy have a
specific beef with the FBI
was it like a case where the feds came
in like straight out of a movie he had
um
jurisdiction right scene
talking on the street with ladies of the
evening
and that uh a couple of Bureau guys
spotted him on the street
with these ladies of the evening
on the way to a meeting
and it made it back to the city council
because the agents were wondering
whether or not they could trust the guy
and they said you know I don't work with
this guy and then he went on to like the
FBI this is how bad it got under this
guy
I don't know if you're familiar with the
FBI National Academy yeah but if you get
if you get sent to the National Academy
Bureau pays all your expenses pays for
your flights like doesn't cost an agency
a dime to send somebody to the National
Academy and it's a stepping stone in a
lot of police departments to be becoming
chief for the next promotion it's a big
deal yeah
and I spoke at the last FBI National
Academy meeting yeah it was awesome so I
get there in the FBI Academy you know uh
October 15th
and they start talking about how they
pay all expenses for cops and I'm
thinking
nobody from Kansas City has come here in
10 years it it can't be that it's free
like now it's free that's that's how
much this guy hated the FBI well
so you get picked up for the FBI uh you
show up to the academy how's the academy
yeah it was good
um
you know running shooting mostly
academic the
um uh the physical aspects of it were
not super challenging
you could if uh it would help you at the
time you could be in no condition at all
and they'd whip you into shape they
ended up having
um
problems with that later on and so now
you can't get in unless you're in at
least a minimal physical condition
but you you could come in and be fat
completely out of shape if you put in
the effort you'd meet the minimums
and they weren't huge like FBI agents
are not wrestling people to the ground
on a regular basis so they want you to
be physically capable
but you know it was more rigorous than a
police department because you you might
get into a wrestling match with somebody
every day
and the bureau's uh tactics is to outman
outgun the bad guys so the physical
confrontations are unnecessary
so they want you to be able to handle
yourself but it's not that big of a deal
they really want you they want you to do
the classroom work they want you to be
able to shoot well my shooting improved
significantly from when I was there and
it was it was it was good solid 16 weeks
it was transformative how are you
looking at because you're a you're a cop
coming off the Mean Streets and how are
you looking at the college kids yeah
they're like uh fun with that with that
interaction yeah it was I was a lot more
um
harsh so to speak more aggressive more
blunt
than the vast majority of them were
um I I was
and they come from all walks of life and
they're going to turn them into agents
but I was you know I was I was a street
cop what percentage of people are
previous cops rolling in there pretty
small
pretty small they at the time
they hired in five categories
I was cops are in the modified category
which is all others like you're not a
lawyer you're not an accountant you're
not a scientist you're not a female
you're not a minority
uh you're not any others you're not a
language you know you don't you're not
already fluent so everybody else goes
into a large categories modified and
you know it's a more competitive
theoretically it's just more more people
there
um and I was modified so not that many
cops was there any uh do you have any
challenges when you were there is
anything hard for you
no I don't think so no nothing nothing
there then I mean I could I was already
in decent condition took care of myself
pretty well I could study when I felt
like it and I already knew how to shoot
do people get kicked out of the academy
like what percentage of people make it
through I mean they got a good screening
progress program so I'm sure it's not
that many no yeah there's well it's even
it's even better now
um
uh and no not that many did not not that
many did like if if you got if you got
caught lying about anything you should
you should be shutting the door
um any any cheating should be shown the
door
if you that was they had a problem with
physical conditioning
because they tried they wouldn't Force
official physical conditioning rules
in the academy but then not once you
join we're actually in a field office as
an agent
and somebody brought up well if if
legally your full FBI agents from the
moment you walk in the door
you shouldn't get fired and from the
academy on something you won't get fired
from if you're in a field office
and
you should be you shouldn't be fat and
out of shape in a field office they just
weren't firing people for that
so they then they then they just raise
the physical minimums to get in the door
are you when you're there
so is is everyone getting trained just
to be an agent yeah and is there do you
go to Specialty training after that so
if I'm an accountant and they think I'm
going to be looking at tax fraud and do
I go there I become an agent and then I
go to an advanced school to be uh you
know a tax fraud guy pretty much exactly
yeah the theory then and I think it
still holds pretty true now like being
an FBI agent first specialize afterwards
we got to make sure that you understand
how to how to be a generalist before you
you know you
follow your bliss for like lack of a
better term like somebody's breaking a
law
on every cool thing you could think of
like if you were into collecting postage
stamps
somebody's engaged in an active criminal
Enterprise making money from accountable
I get a matter
so the cool thing about the FBI is that
ultimately
if you take your time
you can have the best time
investigating crimes around stuff you're
really interested in
but uh if I speak
Spanish or I speak Russian are they
going to throw me into an assignment
where this is my main gig as soon as I
get done Spanish guys for a while
everybody had that if you got hired in
the Spanish program
everybody was going to have to do a
stint in Puerto Rico
those were the only ones at the time
Puerto Rico's
bureau's got his hands full in Puerto
Rico Puerto Rico is
doesn't know if wants to be state or a
commonwealth
you know infrastructure problems uh on
us on the one hand still uh you know
back in my time in a bureau still a
couple of active groups that engaging in
violence for Independence
um
so this just this crazy combination of
very difficult things to working in
Puerto Rico so if you're a Spanish
speaker you're going to do time in
Puerto Rico that was the only language
so as a normal agent would for you for
instance do you get any any say in where
you're going and what you're getting
assigned to no they're just going to
give you what they're going to get not
then but then the bureaus
uh policy which made was made complete
sense
like starting your life over as an FBI
agent it's a big jump
and the easiest way effectively is to go
into witness security program it's a
complete new identity no ties to your
old identity at all because it's the
easiest way to become an FBI agent like
nobody nobody you're not around people
with the high school with you're not
around your neighbors you're not not
even around family oh so you're saying
not literally
like it's witness protection but they
take you and they're not gonna send you
back to where you're from right they're
going to send you to some other city so
you don't have to run into the people
you used to know you're going to be
right it's a new life that was back then
now the problem with that it was very
expensive
to I'm I'm in Kansas City they send me
to Pittsburgh for two years
they get me ready to go into one of
major offices is this what they actually
did with you yeah so this is your first
assignment is Pittsburgh two years in
Pittsburgh you get some kind of a
special assignment like you're gonna be
working gang you're gonna be working
drug you're gonna be or are you just
working
um you most offices start you out
working working applicants
because you got to get used to Landing
credentials on somebody
in a low stress environment so if you're
doing a background investigation you're
walking into a bank because somebody
used to work in a bank wants to become
an agent or something else where the
background's required geez that's not
the rush you were looking for was it
it's a little slow to start I would but
you know the first couple times you know
these crazy things where you hold your
your creds up in front of somebody
you're used to that
and but or if you're going into a bank
to lock somebody up that's a whole
different so they they warm you up in
applicants and then depend upon where
you are where you're gonna get assigned
to I initially get to sign
to foreign counterintelligence FCI
working spies which is not for me
again that's slow meticulous work
and so I within the rules now I'm
scheming on how to get out of there